we're talking about
randomness i wonder if i can weave in uh
quantum mechanics
for a brief moment there's a
you know a lot of advancements on the
quantum computing side
so leveraging quantum mechanics to
perform a new kind of computation
and there's concern of that being a
threat
to a lot of the basic assumptions that
underlie cryptography
what do you think do you think quantum
computing will challenge
a lot of cryptography will cryptography
be able to defend
all those kinds of things okay great so
first of all
for the regular because i think it
matters but it's important
that there are people who can continue
to contend
that quantum mechanics exist but has
nothing to do with computing is not
going to accelerate it
and at least you know um
very basic kind of um are the
computation
that is a belief that you cannot uh uh
take it out
i'm a little bit uh more agnostic about
it but i really believe
going back to whatever i said about the
the one-way function
so one-way function what is it that is a
cryptography
so does quantum computing challenge you
the one-way
function essentially you can boil it
down to does one computing find a runway
function what is one way function
is in one direction are then the other
okay but if quantum computing exists
when you define what it is easy
is not by easy by a classical computer
enacted by a classical computer but easy
for uh for a quantum computer that's a
bad idea
but once easy means it should be easy
for a quantum
and hard for also quantum then you can
see that
you are yes is a challenge but you have
a hope because
you can absorb if one computing really
realizes and
becomes available um uh
according to the promises then you can
use them also for the easy part
and once you use it from the easy part
the
choices that you have a one-way function
they multiply so okay
so the particular candidates of one-way
function
may not be one way anymore
but quantum one-way function may
continue to exist
and so i really believe that
for life to be meaningful with one way
function
had to exist because just imagine
better anything that is becomes easy to
to do i mean what kind of life is it i
mean
so you need the and if something is hard
but it's so hard to generate you'll
never find something which is
hard for you you want but there is
abundance if it is easy to produce
heart problem what's in my opinion is
why life is interesting
because heartbroken pop up another
really
relative speed so in some sense i almost
think that
i do hope they exist if they don't exist
somehow life is
way less interesting than uh it actually
is yeah it does it's
that's funny it does seem like the
one-way function is fundamental to all
of life which is uh the the emergence of
the complexity that we see around us
seem to require the one-way function
i don't know if you uh play with
cellular automata
that's just another formulation of i
know but yeah it's
a very simple it's almost a very simple
illustration of
starting out with simple rules in one
way
being able to generate incredible
amounts of complexity
but then you ask the question can i
reverse that
then it's just it's just a surprising
how difficult it is to reverse that
it's surprising even in constrained
situations
it's very difficult to prove anything
that it almost i mean the sad thing
about it
um i don't know if it's sad but it seems
like we don't even have the mathematical
tools
to reverse engineer stuff i don't i
don't know if they exist or not
but in the space of cellular automata
when you start with something simple and
you create something incredibly complex
can you take something a small picture
of that complex and reverse engineer
that's kind of what we're doing as
scientists here you're seeing the result
of the complexity and you're trying to
come up with some
universal law that generated all of this
what is the
you know the theory of everything what
are the basic physics laws that generate
this whole thing
and there's a hope that you should be
able to do that but
it gets it's difficult but there is also
some portrait of the fact that it's
difficult
right because he he gives us some
mystery
to life which yeah without the witches i
mean
it's not so fun uh all right like
nobody's fun
you